أكد البنتاغون أن
القوات
الأمريكية التي تعمل ببطاريات صواريخ باتريوت المضادة للصواريخ
تعمل هنا في العاصمة الإماراتية
أبو ظبي خارج قاعدة الدفرا الجوية أو حولها ، وهي
قاعدة جوية تستخدمها
القوات الأمريكية والبريطانية على
وجه الخصوص
في المهام القتالية حولها.  الشرق الأوسط
الآن أكد الحوثيون
أنهم أطلقوا بالفعل ما لا يقل عن
صاروخين باليستيين ضد هذه
القاعدة الجوية الاستراتيجية المهمة للغاية وأطلقوا عليها
وبصورة ملحوظة تسميتها
كهدف محتمل ،
عزز البنتاغون مزاعم الحوثيين بالدقة
علاوة على ذلك.  واصل الحوثيون
تحذيراتهم من رجال الأعمال المغتربين
هنا الذين يعيشون بالقرب من
مواقع استراتيجية محتملة للخروج من المدينة كجزء
من ضغوطهم المستمرة التي
يسميها الإماراتيون ضغوطًا
مرعبة مطالبين بإعادة حوثي اليمن إلى
قائمة الإرهابيين التي حددتها الولايات المتحدة وهذا
كله.  في أعقاب محاولات الإماراتيين
الانسحاب فعلياً من
مستنقع  الحرب الأهلية في اليمن لكن ذلك
كله وصل إلى رأس كارثي أو
كارثة قبل أسبوع عندما
قُتل هنا ثلاثة أشخاص في غارة صاروخية أو
طائرة مسيرة أخرى في
جنوب المدينة وأصيب ثمانية آخرون
إثر ذلك أه التحالف بقيادة
السعودية  التي تضم
الإماراتيين الذين ردوا على الحوثيين في
اليمن مما أسفر عن مقتل
عشرات المدنيين
والآن لدينا هذه المحاولة الصاروخية
أه على العاصمة الإماراتية الآن
قال البنتاغون إن القوات الأمريكية كانت
تعمل جنباً إلى جنب مع الإماراتيين وهذا تم
تأكيده  من قبل الإماراتيين ويشير
بوضوح إلى أن الحوثيين بغض النظر
عن
مورديهم للتكنولوجيا في إيران قد يريدون منهم أن
يفعلوا ذلك ، هم عازمون
على الاستمرار والوفاء بتهديداتهم ضد
الإماراتيين سام كيلي سي إن إن في أبو ظبي